well britty Griner was uh arrested in
Russia because she brought a vape pen
that I guess had cannabis oil in it now
was she arrested for that or was she
arrested because uh Russia used her as a
political Pawn because they were about
to invade Ukraine yeah I think we know
why yes okay I imagine that she's you
know snuck yes it's illegal but I
imagine she snuck this vape pen in many
times before she goes there she plays I
think over the Summers I forget what
other wmeacs and but like a lot of
female basketball players they go to
Russian they play on these Russian teams
and these oligarchs in Russia prop up
these female basketball teams in Russia
it doesn't matter whatever so she gets
arrested she's there for months I think
and uh what the U.S and Russia do is a
prisoner swap for basically Brittany
Griner for the Lord of War the Lord of
War you've seen Nicholas the merchants
of the Lord of War was the movie he's
known as The Merchant of death and this
is a guy who's uh basically sold weapons
around the world you know destabilized
tons of [ __ ] African countries now
I'm not acting like we're [ __ ] honest
in this and we're scot-free in this I
imagine we've probably we be in the
United States of America has also
courted this guy and used his specific
skill set to help us in certain
situations so I don't know if we're like
the best that being said we've
definitely arrested him for some reason
and we have him locked up
um so we trade him for Griner and people
are upset they're like that doesn't
really seem like a fair trade I think
this is the reason why it's a little bit
bothersome they've also put in this
other American who is being held there
for months there's a guy who has held
them on charges of Espionage it was a
ex-marine I don't know if you ever asked
but as a Paul Whalen I mean and um so
the the question everybody's asking is
why are you trying to get Brittany
Greiner out who who knowingly broke the
law when you should be trying to get
this American alleged American spy he
just says he's just an American there
who was doing his duty for country now I
don't know what the rules are with spies
when they get caught what you do with
them I don't know Etc I think the issue
with me is it seems like they're they
made the trade for only Brittany for
political points
it seems like it's a little bit of like
a
a little bit of like a virtue signal if
you will trying to get favor with voters
that's what it seems like yeah and you
know there's a Democratic president who
are the constituents that he's going to
support he's going to support gay
minority women it's like oh I check off
three boxes let me get that person back
who does he not have to care as much
about white male Marine who would
probably be voting conservative anyway
so I think there's a little part of me
and I need to know more about the story
but I do I don't like the idea that
we're going to trade this Merchant of
death a guy who's responsible for
probably tens of thousands of deaths and
like destabilization around the world
which we're also responsible for I'm not
saying we're gonna sing but it doesn't
exactly feel like a fair trade and if
you're doing it just to get like a PC
pat on the back
it feels a little gross right when that
same Administration could be letting out
all the weed offenders the non-violent
drug offenders that are in prison right
now the United States it could be
letting every single one of them out
right now and it seems to be perfectly
okay with them continuing to be in jail
in some fairness I do think they're
trying to work on that I do think but I
agree with you but what's to work on you
could just do it it'll work in the
states rights thing yeah you can't just
like flip a switch you could do it
federally you can't do it Statewide but
you could put every single person who's
been convicted of a federal crime that
has to do with drugs they're not violent
at bare minimum just weed yeah you could
immediately especially remove them from
federal prison right now yes or no yes
and he he did pass something but it was
a very small thing it was like a
non-violent but also like uh
it just really it's tough because like
if you have a major drug dealer their
cases usually aren't just oh I just
traffic drugs you know so it's like Al
Capone for tax evasion it's like you're
really getting them for this other [ __ ]
but the only thing you could get them
for is the tax evidence yeah so I feel
that so it's like if you just do this
blanket thing of like oh just
non-violent weed [ __ ] it's like ah this
[ __ ] we know he killed a bunch
of people but we can't charge him on
that exactly now you just let go or he
called for the murders of it which is
totally understandable as well I like I
like everything these things are way
more nonsense yeah uh I just want to
give a little pushback um I don't I
think it's a combination of both I do
think it's political I also do think
they cave to the pressure like did we
did any of us know Whalen was locked up
in Russia no so nobody's tweeting
nobody's commenting but when Brittany
got locked up everybody's tweeting
everybody's saying something you felt
that pressure every conservative that's
upset about it why weren't you talking
about that's what I'm saying him the way
that everybody else is talking about
Brittany yeah like if y'all now granted
breeding grinder is a more famous person
than him sure but make him famous you
have platforms you've got blogs you got
Twitter like every politician that's
complaining that Brittany was taken out
instead of him I need to look at your
tweets and see if you once tweet about
that [ __ ] show some receipts
exactly or are you using
are you using Weyland as a way to score
points against the Democrats yeah now
you're using this [ __ ] who's in
jail this so-called hero you're using a
hero yes so that's foul too but if you
were one of those people people have
been trying to get him out for years and
to know or I guess he's been locked up
for a little while so it's like close to
10 years he's been there I think so oh I
thought I got double checked it was a
six year sentence or something I'm not
sure I'll check but like I I could I
totally understand your frustration if
you've just been clamoring about this
Non-Stop and then to no avail for the
fact that none of us have heard about
him I don't think too many people were
my issue wasn't with Paul Whalen as much
because to me it's like all right they
got a spy we got a Spire we're not a spy
but like a criminal yeah to me the issue
is we're letting out this guy who's like
incredibly dangerous just based on his
history and he's going to just talk
about like from a racial standpoint this
guy is responsible for the death of I
don't know hundreds of thousands of
black kids in Africa oh yeah and
literally what he did he would he would
arm the child soldiers yeah guys okay
now this is not going to be a
politically correct answer but he was a
businessman people are asking hey I won
guns he's not the ones putting the guns
in the kid's hands he's is making the
deal with the guy who's putting the guns
in the kid's hands I would I would I
would step back because it's
what they were doing is arming these
militias in an effort to destabilize
regions that had resources that they
want to make easier to extract yeah but
he just cared about the money at the end
of the day that's why he got caught
because he made a deal that sounded like
a really good deal with a DEA agent just
for the money he didn't give a [ __ ] who
he was selling to no I'm not saying that
his interest was hurting them but he
knew that they were being hurt
McDonald's kills or gives people high
blood pressure and kills people they
don't give a [ __ ] that's the only thing
that's funny I think you're drawing a
parallel on something there's like
degrees of it right everything has
Shades so there's a shade of hey we push
products sometimes on here that aren't
necessarily good for your health that's
different than going to kids and saying
hey here's guns if you're not happy
you're not really smart enough to know
how to handle anything but here's the
guns let's go let's go cause some
turbulence and then we'll benefit and
the US does this so we we're not we
don't have we don't not have blood on
our hands but this guy's a problem
globally and to the U.S so you're not
getting him and if he was doing that
maybe earlier in his career I mean they
found him originally to get him out of
they had to get him out of Russia they
caught him in Thailand like you don't
think for many years of that Russia had
a dealing in how he was actually oh yeah
I'm not like I'm not trying to what I'm
saying I'm just saying that he was he
wasn't every little opportunity he was
definitely taking a side at some point
you know first we're playing chess with
Russia which we always are we bought
guns from them yeah oh yeah he I'm sure
he hired him no no there was a one of
his companies that it was like a shell
company and we found out after that uh
two of his shell companies America
bought guns from for to help like our uh
I don't think anything yeah I don't
think anybody's gonna say America has no
blood on their hands we have plenty
plenty uh but again if we're playing
chess geopolitically which I think we
always are in Russia is one of our main
opponents for lack of a better word you
can't give this guy up it's just like
you got fleece in a trade and maybe
that's why it bothers me as an Indian
because I don't like you losing a
negotiation but you got [ __ ] you got
washed and it's like negotiate I guess
maybe it's worse it's like washed for
what
are we becoming a victim of our own
virtue signal do we need to prove so
much that we care about certain
marginalized groups that we're willing
to put our entire country at risk yeah
like that's a concern are we trying to
show what good people we are so much
that we're forgetting the risks that
that causes and this guy who knows what
he's going to do it's not like he's just
going to retire and go to [ __ ]
ukaterinasburg and get a nice little
village every everybody knows who he is
now so it's like it's easier to
track him and what he's doing
potentially because he's also going to
protect him like they were protecting
him before that's why it's so hard to
get him yeah I don't think there's any
like independent contractors in Russia I
think it all goes back to the top the
other side of things is like weren't we
looking mad [ __ ]
that Brittany was locked up I think this
makes us look for our nine months and we
knew that's like yo that that penalty
was way harsher than the crime like we
were looking a little opposite
what are we supposed to do I know it's a
tough situation that's why this is this
is a big deal what are we supposed to do
it's like do are we supposed to go to
war because Brittany Griner took drugs
to a foreign country not go to war do we
have to try to get around do we have
other prisoners do we have other
leverage points with Russia I don't know
there's no way we only have one prisoner
yeah they wanted they're not stupid they
wanted the most known prisoners they
want to be able to say yo Nicholas Cage
is out of prison for Brittany why didn't
we just give them Nicholas Cage so much
easier
he should have okay but we could just
stop them yeah yeah no it's uh yeah that
[ __ ] is tricky I think they wanted to
embarrass America
and that's what they did so what makes
you look more [ __ ] than not getting
Brittany grinder Home is giving up The
Merchant of death who has caused way
more problems for you and globally for
Brittany grind and have you seen the pr
uh thing that this guy's on uh I saw a
little bit of something on Grand with
this page but he's going through all
these different like uh podcasts
and uh but he's saying all this stuff is
like America's lost their Christian
values and it's like he's trying to
drive the wedge it's really interesting
they're not dumb over there like now
he's a political tool and he's like he's
like you know the people in the middle
of the country they're totally fine and
I got along with them fine and they were
curious about Russia and they were
interested but the people in on the
cities and the coast you know they're
the ones that are so they're buying all
the propaganda about Russia and it's
like huh maybe those Facebook ads
you know what I mean like maybe Russia
maybe Russia was really really doing
some of them Facebook ads like driving
that division so we're fighting each
other here at home instead of actually
focusing on them
yeah it's um there's a 60 Minutes piece
I think fa sent is from like 2012 and
they they did a little thing about how
they locked them up in the sting
operation and you see this guy in jail
he's got he's at like a table he's got
this [ __ ] arms up legs crossed in
shorts and boots and I'm like yo this is
a you this is the baddest [ __ ]
just how little he cares about being in
jail and how comfortable he looks I'm
not letting that guy out ever I'm not
letting you out ever
you're not even remotely affected being
in prison you're just like yeah you got
that guy out that's a problem that's a
bad [ __ ] I'm sure he saw the
camera he's like sure sure I still
wouldn't be able to act that well yeah I
mean God looks fine no bruises no
nothing
I can't touch this guy up in prison yeah
yeah
it's a tough system I just wish we could
have negotiated better to like get
multiple people yeah or to trade for a
lesser first round draft picks yeah you
know what I mean something like miles
brought this up before like we had
traded with Russia for like a Russian
pilot and like a drug Smuggler
um we April yeah there was like a
journalist that was there an American
journalist who got captured in Russia
who's ex-marine oh he's actually Marine
yeah and so yeah he's over there and
then there's a Russian pilot that got
captured in the U.S for like drug
smuggling and they traded in April okay
that was a better trade on for us that's
my point so I'm like that's what I'm
saying like I have a feeling we're gonna
get that Paul Whalen guy back they just
wanted this to be a trade that made us
look stupid it can't cause more
invitings they want the worst guy who
had a movie made after him yeah to be
traded for the girl that I don't know
like that's a [ __ ] incredible trade
that's how you kind of embarrass I guess
America now what Russia doesn't realize
is we don't give a [ __ ] for about
anything for more than three days so
like we Russ is thinking oh we got him
there's gonna be a real thorn on their
side we Britney Greiner well nobody will
care about in three days unless she like
dunks or does something in a basketball
game and then we'll just go and be like
see how boring basketball is when women
play like it we'll just go right back to
normal of not giving a [ __ ] about the
WNBA the WNBA had their time to shine
and we'll go right back not giving a
[ __ ] the person I feel bad about
is Paul Whalen because for a few weeks
it felt like the whole United States of
America really was doing willing to do
anything to get them back and he might
have got his hopes up he might be
talking his family back home like oh
they're trying to do it it looks like it
might be it they're going to get you and
Brittany and now they get Brittany and
it's like sayonara see you later you're
gonna be in this [ __ ] jail for the
next six years yeah I mean like I I I'm
not saying I don't feel bad for him but
at the same time he had four passports
he was uh I think like he's a spy yeah
like pushed out of the [ __ ] military
like hey you know the risk of what
you're doing so it's like okay I think
it was like oh is that the story oh
that's what like I would if we could
only go by what we see on paper my point
is if I'm a spy
if I'm going to be a good spy in another
country you can't look at my record and
be like Four Star General incredible but
loyalty of being a spy going to play in
Russia at that time was also no
it wasn't hot no when they locked her up
this was way before the war started like
there was tensions it was like three or
four weeks and the war started years ago
bro they've been playing there for years
with no problem no I'm sure they're
playing there for years sorry miles can
you just check the timeline I think it
was like fairly shortly but it's like
pretty sure like quickly before the war
we didn't know it was going to happen
before but first of all we don't know
what we knew they knew that they were
going to do it no matter what exactly
but not in America but I I have a
feeling if Russia is going to pla plan a
war we're gonna know that there might be
a war happening